Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
They say 1% can solve this problem.
You need to select three of the balls and place them in the circles,
such that the numbers on the balls have a sum of 30.
You're allowed to use a number more than once but you must use exactly three of the balls.
This problem was sent to me by email and there are many popular variations of this puzzle across the internet.
I thought this was a fun variation I wanted to share.
Pause the video if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
Recall the rules of parity. An even number plus or minus an even number will always be an even number. An
even number plus or minus an odd number will always be an odd number.
Finally, an odd number plus or minus an odd number will always be an even number. In this problem,
we're only dealing with sums. In particular, we want the sum of three odd numbers. To get that,
we'll add an odd number to both sides of the very last equation.
We end up with the result of an even number plus an odd number which we know from the second rule is equal to an
odd number. Therefore, the sum of three odd numbers will always be an odd number.
So, how can we get three numbers to have a sum of 30 if we're limited to the odd numbers from 1 to 15? We
can't! It's mathematically impossible.
But this is not strictly a mathematical problem. This is a puzzle.
So what's the trick? The clue is that the balls have the same colors as billiard balls. Take a look at the green colored ball.
We can orient it in
three-dimensional space. In
particular, you might know the trivia that the green colored ball in a standard set of billiard balls is the number 6.
We turn the 9 upside down to get the even number 6.
We then solve the puzzle by adding the numbers 11 and 13.
6 plus 11 plus 13 is equal to 30, and that's the answer to this puzzle.
There's an important lesson: When a problem seems impossible, try changing your perspective!
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.